good morning Hank it's Tuesday and I'm
wearing a suit today to try to appeal to
advertisers but don't worry I haven't
sold out you can tell because I'm not
wearing any pants I wasn't supposed to
go like that huh okay sorry I had to
change it was just so hot and I could
feel corporate America constricting me
and it was unbearable so Hank on Sunday
I made a video and many nerdfighters
commented that almost all of the ads
next to my face and right down here were
about either Scientology or mail-order
brides now Hank I want to clarify
something we don't want nerdfighters to
become Scientologists mail-order brides
nor in fact do we want them to use the
Internet to purchase mail-order brides
for one thing buying a life on the
Internet is immoral and for another
thing dang it
also Inc this isn't the first time that
the advertisements on our video have
been hilarious and/or humiliating this
one for instance just seems to be making
fun of you and I found this one a little
bit troubling as well I mean first off
Google are you trying to make my wife
worry just because I like dressing up my
bust of Edgar Allen Poe and secondly
that ad leads to a website where you can
buy a test to find out if your husband
is gay now admittedly Hank I haven't
purchased this test so I don't know how
great it is but as a public service I am
now going to provide a free identical
test question 1 hey husband
do you like dudes question 2 seriously
go do you all right let me tell you what
I don't think selling out is I don't
think it's selling out to tell the
people who watch our videos that I write
books and I don't think it's selling out
to say that the paperback edition of
Paper Towns comes out on September 17th
and it looks approximately like this
well I mean not not not exactly like
this I mean the book will have like you
know stuff in the middle I don't even
think it would be selling out if I
arranged my bookshelves every video to
look like that although it would be a
little bit unseemly which is why I don't
do it even though my publishers are
always asking me to and I don't think
it's selling out when you make an
awesome CD that you work hard on and
then tell people they can buy by the way
Hank's album is brilliant and it will
change your life link in the sidebar
telling me it's selling out to try to
share my books with an audience it's
like telling Derek Jeter it's selling
out when he tries to hit balls hard or
telling your mom she's selling out if
she hits balls hard I guess your mom
jokes don't really work when your mom is
also my mom on the other hand Hank I
think
would be selling out if we told people
or implied to them that they couldn't be
made of Awesome nerdfighters unless they
bought this stuff now Hank as you know
we don't do paid product placement in
our videos not because we think it's
inherently wrong but because we don't
think it's right for us and our audience
here's my problem with paid product
placement I may believe that wacky
string is the best silly string product
on the planet which I do and I may tell
my friends that when they have silly
string needs they should turn to wacky
string but if wacky string pays me to
say that I'm not saying it because it's
true I'm saying it because they paid me
on the other hand we do make money from
advertising and from selling t-shirts
now obviously Hank you two can't survive
without advertising and as we make this
more of our job we can't survive without
advertising either because like I assume
that no one wants to pay for
vlogbrothers videos I mean hey you're my
brother and I'm myself but even I don't
want to pay to watch our videos but Hank
the nerdfighter community is so
tight-knit and so focused on making the
world suck less that I don't want
questions about selling out swirling
around and pulling us apart so
nerdfighters in comments please let us
know do you think that talking about
money is just kind of gross and
generally trust us not to sell you out
do you be you want to see a fuller and
more transparent accounting of what
money goes to us and what money goes to
charity or do you see one I have a kind
of shareholder role in the nerdfighter
community where you vote on what our
compensation should be and as a bonus
question what do you think the
definition of selling out is
nerdfighters please know that you never
have to buy anything to be a nerdfighter
and you particularly do not have to buy
a wife although it's worth noting just
for the public record that if you click
on a mail-order bride ad and then don't
order a bride the company loses money
Hank we've been brothers for 29 years
and you've never sold me out and I
appreciate it
I'll see you tomorrow PS hey Chicagoans
I'm doing a nerdfighter gathering in
your City next Thursday more info in the
sidewall